the world suddenly doesn't care about
the war in Ukraine I actually
experienced this we recently published a
video about drone Warfare in the war in
Ukraine and it was one of the more
ambitious videos I've ever made and yet
it like flopped and I I don't have
videos flop very often this is weird and
I was scratching my head until I started
to realize that the world is losing
interest in this war like this was like
the focus of the entire world for years
Western people and governments have been
pouring money and attention and support
on Ukraine since Russia invaded But now
governments are debating whether or not
they should give any money or weapons to
Ukraine anymore people have turned their
attention to other things the war in
Israel is pulling people's attention
away global conflict really relies on
global attention a conflict like the war
in Ukraine could be one or Lost based on
how much we pay attention to it how much
we pressure our government to continue
to support it that support seems to be
waning and the people of Ukraine and
their leaders are pretty nervous if you
want to better understand global
politics follow along for more